this episode is brought to you by
curiosity stream a subscription
streaming service that offers over 2000
documentaries and nonfiction titles
unlimited access starting at just $2.99
a month and 30 days for free if you sign
up at curiosity stream calm /ba graphics
and news code by graphics more on them
in a bit you're probably familiar with
the musical Evita by Tim Rice and Andrew
Lloyd Webber which tells the true story
of Eva Duarte and her relationship with
Argentinean President Juan Peron in the
most famous number don't cry for me
Argentina Evita addresses the crowds
after orchestrating an insurrection to
free her husband's prisoner to her
military Hunza a young Che Guevara
witnesses the events providing some
commentary in song form of course so how
much of this famed musical scene is true
and how much is just dramatized dreamers
well we'll find out together in today's
by graphics which covers the lives of
Evita and Juan perón's who illegitimate
children who rose from obscurity to
ultimate power
[Music]
Maria Eva Duarte Layton known simply as
Eva or Evita was born on May the 7th
1919 in the town of los told us in the
Argentine pampas or Fertile islands she
was the youngest of five children bought
two Hana a beggar gun and wand where Tay
Kwan and Juana were nor Mary
in fact her father had a second official
family bond was a wealthy and successful
farm manager with close ties to rich
landowners and the elite members of the
conservative party after Eva's birth
this party started losing ground to the
radicals which caused a decline in
Haun's fortunes the Duarte is accustomed
to relative wealth had to tighten the
belt a few years later dancer punched
some extra holes in the belt all
together when Han died in a car accident
on the 8th of January 1926 cuando arte
had never recognized the children he has
with Quanah meaning they would receive
no inheritance this humiliation was
compounded by the treatment received at
Hans funeral his lawful widow and her
wealthy family physically prevented Vita
and her siblings from attending the
service this was a watershed moment
innovators upbringing the knowledge that
she was an explicit part of the lower
rungs of Argentinian society ostracized
by the rich elite by the time Eva
started first grade her other siblings
Juan Jr and ELISA were already working
as clark's while mum Juana spent hours
on her sewing machine as a self-employed
seamstress
Eva was not yet burdens with these
responsibilities and she would spend her
school free hours climbing trees and
exploring the countryside perhaps most
importantly she enjoyed dressing up and
improvising plays for her friends and
her siblings her co-star was second
youngest sister am endurance they could
counts on Horne jr. as the stage
designer in 1930 the Duarte is moved to
the town of Hoonah in it was here that
Eva's penchant for dress-up games
evolved into a full-blown passion for
acting with a rich data films watched at
the village cinema and radio dramas she
also joined a school drama group and
performed for the first time on stage by
1934 at the age of 15 Eva made her
choice she would move to Ueno Cerys and
become a professional actress her mother
Hana was not sold on the idea how could
a girl so young
face the dangers of the big capital
according to some accounts it was
celebrity tango singer Agustin Miguel D
who convinced Juana to let Eva follow
her dreams in the rice Weber music all
the much older Miguel D is portrayed as
Eva's lover and the two elope to Buenos
Aires a less dramatic but more likely
version of events comes courtesy of
Eva's older sister a min de it was the
headmaster of Eva school who had noticed
the girls talents and convinced mum
Juana to let the girl press her fortune
with acting and before you start
gossiping no Eva did not elope with the
headmaster there was no eloping here it
was Juana who took a theater to Buenos
Aires and arranged for her to move in
with some family friends this was the
beginning of her adventure Argentina in
the 1930s was a nation struggling under
the weight of poverty unemployment and
hunger this was the case in much of the
rest of the world as well following the
financial collapse of 1929 tens of
thousands of Argentines moved from the
farms in the countryside into Buenos
Aires looking for better working and
living conditions year after year the
social gap widens between the upper and
middle classes and the desperately poor
this was the backdrop for Eva's first
steps in professional acting as she too
struggled to make a living amidst fierce
competition but she clearly had Talent
reigns and beauty which is always a
powerful combination Eva was soon hired
by the Campania Argentina to camellias
professional troupe and she made her
debut in March 1935 in 1937 Eva turned
18 and her career went from strength to
strength she first appeared on the
silver screen and then on the radio
while her roles on stage and in cinema
mainly were bit paths or supporting
characters it was on the radio where Eva
could get her best parts and really
progressed her career and it was radio
not cinema that made her a household
name in Argentina a co-star in one of
her many radio dramas complemented
either labeling her as professional
dependable and talented but Eva also
picked up a reputation as well not
exactly the nicest person to be around
it seems that Eva was generally not
liked by many of her colleagues it may
have been these same colleagues who
later spread rumors that Eva's
career was accelerated by a propensity
to sleep with the right people it is
more likely though that these rumors
were circulated after she had become
mrs. Perrin in order to undermine the
president neither him nor Evita would
ever lack enemies whatever the truth Eva
Duarte surely did not lack talent as she
was routinely signed up for one radio
drama after the other in 1943 eva
reached the peak of her popularity as
the star of and I'm not joking here a
biography show yeah that's why I do what
I do step number one host a biography
show step number two running a country
step number three musical named after me
perfect joking aside
Eva's joke was a collection of
dramatizations in which she played the
role of women who had made history like
Elizabeth the first Catherine the Great
is a Dora Duncan and Sarah Bernhardt
among others I wonder if she could
imagine that one day her own life story
could have been dramatized in such a
show 1943 was a year of importance not
just to Eva but to all Argentinians On
June the fourth a military coup led by
General Pedro Ramirez seized power from
the president Ramon Castillo within the
grieve of conspirators there was an
ambitious Colonel he was put in charge
of the Ministry of Labour and Welfare
his name was Colonel Juan Peron
[Music]
Juan Domingo perón was born in Los Lobos
a province of Buenos Aires on October
the 8th 1895 like either Juan was born
out of wedlock the child of wealthy
farmer Mario Tomas Paran and
ohana Sousa Juan spent most of his
childhood and early teenage years in the
pampas in the south of the country he
always wished to return to the capital
to study medicine but when he did return
to Buenos Aires it was to enter the
military academy in 1911 he graduated in
1913 barely eighteen with the rank of
second left Hannon's in the infantry
Juan was amongst the first of his class
and he gained a reputation as a
hard-working students he also excelled
in physical training standing at six
foot tall and being solidly built the
young athletic Juan became an army
champion in boxing skiing and fencing he
even almost made it onto the Argentine
Olympic fencing team as Argentina never
entered a war during his early military
career
Don only knew about peacetime deployment
he progressed through the ranks thanks
to his academic endeavors as well as the
publication of several books on military
morals and hygiene in 1925 kwon mess
with seventeen-year-old Aurelia tzur
after a four-year engagement the two
married on January the 5th 1929 Aurelia
was a teacher intelligence and
academically minders a valuable
companion for Peron aralia dedicated
much of her time to translating military
theory textbooks from english for a
husband
in 1939 the now captain Braun was a
member of the Army Staff as well as a
professor of military history at the
higher Institute for war studies he
continued publishing textbooks and
expanded his field of knowledge into
linguistics with the book on the
language of the indigenous people from
in and around Patagonia in 1936 Braun
had become a major and was tasked with a
delicate assignment officially he was
detached as a military attache to the
Argentinian embassy in Chile
unofficially Kwon was actually spying on
the Chilean Army in search of potential
plans for an invasion of Argentina which
was an event feared to be likely at that
time
Peron was a skilled agent reporting on
Chile's military capabilities without
ever blowing his cover this success may
have earned him his next promotion to
left hanok colonel at the end of the
same
yeah on September the 10th 1938 after a
prolonged period of illness Aurelia died
young at the age of 30 the diagnosis was
cervical cancer this was a devastating
blow to the officer a valued asset to
Argentina's military her own state of
depression worried his superiors to the
point that they offered him another post
abroad to get his mind off the tragedy
from 1939 to the beginning of 1940 Braun
was attached to the Army's European
mission of Foreign Studies this involved
him touring Italy Spain Germany Hungary
and France to study and observe those
countries militaries he spent most of
his time in Italy here Perron focused on
mounds in warfare but he also had the
chance to study closely the policies and
authoritarian methods of benito
mussolini while never fully at hearings
a fascist ideology Braun came to
appreciate the dictatorial methods in
use in Italy and in other European
countries he started to appreciate the
notion of strong direct authoritarian
rule as the only means to impose
effective reforms in his home country
von Braun returns to Argentina in 1941
having risen to the rank of colonel
the country at that time was ruled by
President Herman Castillo whose term had
become unpopular due to widespread
corruption fraud economic stagnation and
an increasing divide between the upper
and lower classes this is when Peron
started getting involved in politics he
joined a secret outfit called G o u
grupo oficial 'as Unidos or group of
united officers which had a nationalist
agenda in july 1943 the geo you seized
power in an almost bloodless coup
General Arturo rawson took power in
roughly the amount of time needed to
choose the color scheme for his office
curtains rawson was favorable to the
Allied cause in World War 2 and was open
to civilians and his cabinet but his
fellow conspirators they disagreed with
both ideas rawson was promptly replaced
with General Pedro Ramirez whose agenda
and methods were much more closely
aligned to the Axis powers firmly anti
leftist and totalitarian Ramirez
appointed general Farrell as Minister of
War who brought along Perrin as his
personal secretary this was not enough
for the ambitious colonel who
volunteered for a post that nobody
the Minister of the National Labor
Department it wasn't just a move to get
a seat in the cabinet but a calculated
first step in a long term plan so now
just before I continue with today's
video I do want to thank curiosity
stream for making it possible making
super long videos like this one is only
possible because of our fantastic
sponsors curiosity stream is a
subscription streaming service that
offers over 2000 documentaries and
nonfiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers including
exclusive originals if you're looking
for a specific recommendation from me on
the platform well check out 101 events
that made the 20th century now if you're
enjoying this video I think that'd be a
great fit for you or if you enjoy any of
our figures from the 20th century it's
gonna be a good fit while serious it's
also pretty chilled it comes out of
Australia so there's this Australian guy
narrating yet very relaxing nice accent
does a great job I've recommended it
before it just felt that with the
figures for today's video it's just
gonna be a great fit for this video as
well it's a really good series so go
check it out now curiosity stream is
available on many platforms the web app
Roku Android Xbox one Smart TVs iOS it
goes on and is also available worldwide
so get unlimited access starting at just
two dollars 99 and month and for our
audience the first 30 days completely
free if you sign up a curiosity stream
calm /ba graphics and use the promo code
by graphics it's all one word lowercase
no quotes during the signup process this
is a great way to support the show and
it keeps us making more videos since I
really couldn't think of a better fit
given that you know our videos are all
educational and curiosity stream is all
educational I think you guys are really
liked it so check them out linked below
and let's carry on with today's video
[Music]
Minister Perrin delivered an astounding
amount of reform in the span of two
years all of which gained in the
supports of the masses of industrial
workers for example he introduced paid
holidays for all workers he also limited
work hours and mandated better working
conditions Perron also established a
system of governments affiliated trade
unions to defend workers rights and
always intervened on their side against
industry owners he did not refrain from
using government funds to pay for worker
salaries or pensions when factory owners
threatened to suspend payments these
progressive policies certainly benefited
the lower classes which made Peron
increasingly popular this was his
strategy bolster the status of workers
the majority of the population which
would grant him support and even
devotion in return Varane referred to
his supporters as the desk a Masada's or
shirtless now Argentinian was under the
illusion that Perron operated within a
democracy this was a military
authoritarian government but unlike
previous democratic cabinets perang
delivered on January the 15th 1944 a
national emergency put per on to the
test
an earthquake completely obliterated the
province of San Juan killing 7,000
inhabitants and injuring another 12,000
for an organized nationwide campaign to
raise funds to aid the wounded and the
displaced for this effort he drafted
national celebrities to a system
including popular actors from the stage
cinema and radio some days later Eva set
up a meeting with Juan in his office
during which she asked for more
opportunities to raise funds for the
earthquake victims it was then that
Peron felt an immediate attraction for
the young actress he later recalls as I
looked at her I felt that her words were
taking over me I was almost subjugated
by the warmth in her voice and in her
eyes and just like that an expert of
coup de tiara a veteran of a coup d'etat
were brought together by a coup de thoux
if you'll pardon my french the two
initially kept their relationship a
secret why well the age difference might
have played a part as he was 49 and she
was 25 but well it was also their
business besides their romantic lives
their careers went from strength to
strength in early 1944 piron's patron
general farrell became presidents and he
appointed his protege
as vice president and Minister of War on
top of his labor duties evil was no less
overworked hosting three daily radio
shows one on biographies one on
geography and one on top ten items okay
not really it was actually two radio
dramas and a propaganda broadcast in
support of the regime on July the 9th
1944 the two lovebirds decided to go
public with their relationship by
showing up together at a gala event
Varane had become the most popular
member of the regime enjoying great
visibility with the press and well so
did Vita appearing by his side in public
in March of 1945 president Farrell
opportunistically declared war on the
Axis powers
securing a place in the United Nations
for Argentina in August he decided to
soften his regime even promising free
elections by the end of the year in the
meantime pran had fallen out of favor
with the political establishment his
populist reforms had alienated the
support of the more traditional elements
of the ruling classes the military in
the church Evita had also come under
attack accused of being only a
power-hungry social climber little more
than a prostitute the Power couples
downward descent was prologue to perón's
appointment of a Vitas friend as head of
the department of posts and Telegraph
her on was forced to resign on October
the 10th 1945 by the 13th he was
arrested on the island of Martin Garcia
years later her on recalls how Evita
immediately organized general labor
strike followed by a massive
demonstration of the desk a Mossad aahs
she marched at the head of hundreds of
thousands of workers occupying Plaza de
Mayo in Buenos Aires the square in front
of the seat of the government Evita then
addressed the crowds from a balcony a
young Che Guevara was among them this
was remembered as the foundation day of
Peto nice small or not Juan Peron is the
only source to ever circulate this
version of the events which was later
incorporated into the musical in reality
Evita
likely did not play a role in the
uprising at all the strike was
spontaneous as were the mass
demonstrations that s commissar dos they
rallied in plaza de meyer demanding for
braun to be released the authorities
hoping to prevent bloodshed they
complied with their demands asking
parang to step onto the balcony to calm
down the mob
and how about a Vera well he was 17 at
the time and he was still attending
secondary school and did not move to
Buenos Aires until 1947 he never met
Evita there only recorded contact is a
letter he wrote asking if she could buy
him a Jeep
as soon as Ferran was released from
prison he did two things he resigned
from the military leaving with the rank
of general and he married Evita
in a registry office on the 22nd of
October followed by a religious ceremony
on the 10th of December with the V
Tobias side / on set off to organize his
candidature in the new general elections
he ran as a candidate from the party
daily barista or Labour Party his
opposition the Democratic Union was a
disparate coalition that included both
conservatives and communists with the
open backing of US ambassador Braden his
influence was so extensive that the
electoral choice was often presented as
Peron versus Braeden Hahn and Evita
organized an intense campaign trail with
a chartered trained called eldest cam
asado this was the first time in the
history of Argentina that a presidential
Canada was accompanied by his wife On
February the 8th 1946 she pioneered
another first at a party rally she
replaced Juan on the speaker's podium as
he was too ill to speak unfortunately
that was a total disaster while workers
loved were on thanks to his earlier
reforms they were still mistrustful of
his wife the crowds would not let her
speak drowning her out with cries of we
want / on us little by little a visa
grew in popularity her acting talent
trained voice and overall good looks
helps in no small measure On June the
4th 1946 the couple found their victory
hon Ron had been democratically elected
the new presidents of Argentina and
Evita had become the first lady at 27
years of age
Juan perón's presidency is not easily
defines if not as a labyrinth of
contradictions let's begin with his
ideology known as host Elise ma or just
isseul ISM it was founded on social
justice and heavy state intervention in
the form of welfare programs to support
the lower classes but it was also known
as para nice more an indication that
this movement was a unique way of
running a country centered around the
cult of Juan perón's personality and
strong leadership Juan Peron introduced
several progressive reforms mainly to
the benefits of his electoral base the
working classes
he made social security education and
health care totally free and universal
he introduced maternity leave ins the
right to vote for women with Evita zki
contribution Perron also boosted the
Argentine economy by developing
hydroelectric power plants launching a
local iron and steel industry and
expanding shipbuilding by 500% but to
achieve all this he implemented rash
authoritarian measures including
censorship of the press and
incarceration of dissenters in terms of
foreign policy
perron strategy for Argentina was to
become a neutral country along 8th
position aligned with neither capitalism
nor communism during the Cold War in
practice Bron did not hide his hostility
towards American and British presence or
influence over Argentina was he secretly
considering a drift towards Moscow
though well not exactly
after becoming president von Braun made
Argentina a well-known haven for former
Nazis out of Eichmann Josef Mengele Eric
Kripke Otto Skorzeny
and many many many other war criminals
all found refuge their scores any even
became a bodyguard to the parens and may
well have had a liaison with Evita a
rumor that was never confirmed all of
these Nazi officials except the Scorsone
had been sentenced in absentia at the
Nuremberg trials and were wanted for
crimes against humanity
Peron was doing more than just accepting
them into his country here he actively
invited them offering money houses and
jobs so what was his plan Peron had
estimated that a new world war would
break out by 1949 for to buy the bloc's
led by the US and the Soviet Union
his end strategy was to bargain for
Argentina's participation on the western
side and that's when the expertise of
ex-nazi
would have come in handy they were
trained officers adept at fighting the
Soviets in June 1947 Evita had a first
official trip abroad the rainbow tour
across Europe and South America her
first leg of the tour was in Spain where
she met Generalissimo Francisco Franco
considered to be one of the last
vestiges of fascism in Europe this did
not help the image of the parents in
subsequent visits to Italy and
Switzerland Evita was accused of being
the representative of a fascist country
and was booed or even pelted with eggs
and rotten fruit during her official
visit to London she was snubbed by the
king upon returning from Europe Evita
dedicated herself to the cause of
women's suffrage she had already
supported a bill to that effect in 1946
and she now wanted things to change and
for them to change fast
Evita launched an appeal to Argentinian
women who staged two massive rallies in
September of 1947 and plastered Buenos
Aires with posters on September the 23rd
Parliament ratified the bill suffrage
was truly Universal in Argentina if he -
capped the achievement two years later
by founding the first all-female party
in Argentina to ensure that women would
be on the ballot not just at the ballot
if eita
understood her feminist victory would
not have been possible without the
backing and active participation of her
husband in her writing she made it clear
that in order to bring about progress
both male and female actions were
necessary
she summarized this is a man of action
triumph over everyone else a woman of
action triumph for everyone else in
other words male action was needed to
overcome opposition when imposing new
ideas but female action was a
constructive energy the ones who really
bring those new ideas do the benefits of
others inspired by these ideals Evita
threw herself into welfare work and by
1947 she had become a sort of unofficial
Minister of Labour committing to a
grueling work schedule of up to 22 hours
a day meeting trade union delegations
and addressing welfare issues examples
of a work included organising
state-funded holiday camps for workers
children building hospitals for textile
industry employees and distributing aid
to the poorest family
in the country and because she had two
hours left each day
Evita put that time to good use to
compliments her aid efforts she created
the foundation Eva Peron focused on
helping women children and the elderly
she collected funds mainly as donations
from trade unions and channeled them
into several initiatives such as the
construction of schools and hospitals
the foundation continued to finance and
develop major works in the field of
education and health care during the
early 1950s with Evita supervising most
of them at this stage even Peron
supporters could not help but wonder
where the required funds came from
officially they came from voluntary
donations by trade unions as well as
private enterprises there was strong
suspicion that these donations were
enforced by threats either donate or
face the consequences take for example
the candy factory called MooMoo the
company was forcibly shut down by the
government with all of its employees
losing their job allegedly it was
because of poor hygienic conditions
inside the factory but if eaters direct
involvement in a subsequent meeting
between factory management and trade
unions led to suspicions that MooMoo was
being punished for failing to donate to
the foundation in 1949 honduran
succeeded in having a new constitution
ratified by Parliament's this new text
involved a new rounds of reforms such as
universal suffrage and even a
declaration of the rights of the elderly
drafted by Avitus foundation but the
main aim of the Constitution was to
allow for one to run for a second term
in future elections as was often the
case Evita would play a key role by his
side this time though it would be a more
explicit institutionalized one because
in August of 1951 the trade unions
formally asked von Braun to run again
for presidents this time with Evita as
his vice presidents despite popular
enthusiasm for the idea Evita
eventually declined this may have been
due to pressure from military leadership
who always disliked the first lady
another reason may have been Vitas own
poor health she had been suffering from
fatigue frequent fainting and vagina
bleeding today we know that all these
symptoms pointed to a diagnosis of
cervical cancer the same illness that
had killed piron's first wife but
residents had decided to hide the truth
from the Vita for reasons that are still
unclear perhaps it was to shield her
from a devastating diagnosis or perhaps
he just wanted to hide the truth from
the public in a cynical electoral move
Peron did not want to reveal that Evita
perhaps the biggest source of his
presidential popularity may not even be
alive during his second term in office
von Braun won the elections in November
of nineteen fifty one with a 62%
majority the Vita appeared by his side
as he was sworn in it was one of her
last public appearances if it's a bronze
last month on earth were painful the
official version of her death on July
the 26th 1952 is that this was caused by
late stage cervical cancer it may not be
a coincidence that piranhas first wife
Aurelia had suffered the same fate one
of the causes of cervical cancer is
infection by HPV the human papilloma
virus it is likely that Juan Peron was a
carrier of such a virus and thus had
infected both of his wives in 2015 a new
explanation for Avitus demise was put
forward by dr. Daniel Newton son
neurosurgeon at Yale University Medical
School Nielsen had obtained scans with
etus skull after a death which showed
signs of being drilled into this was
evidence that the first lady had
received a lobotomy an operation that
involves cutting the neural connections
between the prefrontal lobes and the
rest of the brain in order to numb
emotional responses one possibility is
that the lobotomy had been a radical
measure to manage the pain of her cancer
but a more sinister one is that Juan had
ordered the lobotomy to curb a Vitas
increasingly unpredictable behavior as
she succumbed to cancer Avitus actions
were becoming more and more extreme in
the last months of life Evita called for
violent action against her enemies and
the enemies of the people which she
identified as the oligarchs in
traditional Argentinian society it
appeared that she even ordered from her
sickbed a consignment of 5000 automatic
pistols and 1500 machine guns to arm the
trade unions she was seriously risking
the onset of a civil war the news it
would have been enough to tear apart the
factions of Juan perón's allies who
already objected to Vitas power and
polarity the country it really could
have descended into conflict according
to dr. Nielsen the lobotomy was
performed by an American surgeon James
poppin within the presidential palace
Poppins nurse reported that poppin had
practiced the operation on convicts that
were taken from Buenos Aires prisons
medically the intervention was at least
a partial success as Evita did not die
immediately it also succeeded in
silencing her Thurgood the lobotomy put
her in a catatonic state and she stopped
eating
her health deteriorated quickly until
her death in July at the age of 33 eight
months after Peron had been reelected
the masses mobilized one last time for a
funeral with thousands of citizens
following the procession Vitas body who
is placed at the headquarters of the
general Labor Confederation while they
publicly funded mausoleum was being
built Juan perón ordered that her body
be perfectly embalmed her body thus
became a sort of relic to be adored by
the masses sort of a fitting end
considering that the Pope immediately
started receiving requests for Evita to
become a saint by late 1952 Juan Peron
realized that he could not continue his
policies of public spending forever the
country's finances were sluggish and the
economy was stagnating
moreover the death of Evita had dealt a
hard blow to his popularity exacerbated
by rumors that it started dating a
14-year old girl
Catholic authorities and the military
they were not happy Braun changed his
foreign policy in an effort to revive
the economy
traditionally anti-american he made a
u-turn and looked for reproach meant
with Washington a move that should have
revived Argentina's exports to the US
but it was only a matter of time before
a new conspiracy ended his tenure in
office this happens on September 16 from
1955 a coup led by the more
traditionalist Ashlyn's of the Navy and
the Air Force took power after shelling
positive Myo and causing 400 casualties
Braun was forced into exile by the new
military hanja he first moved to
Paraguay and five years later landed in
Madrid by the time he was in Spain had
taken a third wife Maria Estella
Martinez who was an Argentinian dancer
that are known as Isabel in the meantime
the Hunter had forbidden all aspects of
piron's policies displaying images of
Juan Peron and
was also forbidden this man extended to
the Vita's body in 1955 it was removed
from its mausoleum no one could account
for her body for the ensuing 16 years
some cynical soul once said that the ex
you can't compete with is the dead one
Isabelle Martinez certainly must have
felt that way
this Chien Han led a life of luxury in
Madrid former president Perron never
stopped looking for a Vitas embalm
remains in 1971 out of nowhere came the
revelation that if eita had been
secretly buried in a cemetery in milan
under a headstone bearing a different
name Juan Barone recovered a body had it
restored by mortician and kept it for
some days in his Madrid home not just
anywhere though he had it lying on a
table in his living room and Isabelle
would be asked to brush Avitus hair
every day to make sure it didn't tangle
I'm not gonna comment on this in the
video but feel free to below so you're
back to normality in 1973 public
pressure in Argentina demanded for
parent returned from his exile the
president's in charge general the noose
complied and invited Kwan to return to
the homeland so Juan and Isabel moved
back to Buenos Aires on June the 20th
1973 lanuza
also called for general elections to
take place in March but had made a point
that Perron should not be allowed to run
this was not a problem as he
participated and won by proxy a revived
Justi stylist party put forward another
candidate mr. camara who won with a thin
majority of 49.5 9% after taking power a
camp aura immediately resigns initiating
new elections in September which of
course allowed for Perron to participate
pretty sly move wanan is about Perron
campaigned together as president and
vice president respectively scoring a
60% victory by the end of the year Juan
had become presidents of Argentina for a
third time with his wife a
second-in-command Isabelle had succeeded
in gaining the vice presidency a post
that would have perfectly suited Evita
if it weren't for her illness bronze
that was short-lived as he died of a
heart attack on July the 1st 1974 Isabel
succeeded him as president the first
female head of government in the Western
Hemisphere so I really hope you enjoyed
today's super long video the story of
this couple was just really interesting
so we felt that it deserves some extra
time feel free to you know like share
subscribe etc we just got a final
question for you is there any other
historical character from a music
show they'd like us to cover let us know
in the comments below also please do
check out our fantastic sponsor
curiosity stream link below and thank
you for watching
[Music]